i
very much welcome the preparation and
cooperation
of the portuguese recovery and
resilience plan
your priorities and ambitions
mirror exactly those of next generation
eu
the european union's large recovery plan
for
reforms and investment
next generation eu allows the commission
to raise 750 billion euros
on the market today in order to invest
it
in a stronger future for tomorrow
portugal also has
a head start especially when it comes to
the twin
green and digital transition portugal
is already a digital leader
in many areas and it is catching up fast
in
others every year you know better than
me
lisbon hosts 80 000 of the world's
most renowned tech professionals
at the web summit portugal
has always been a front runner in the
transition towards cleaner energy
and this is thanks to strong government
and
private sector support support for wind
for title for solar and other forms of
renewables
portugal will be a strong beneficiary
of next generation eu
it will help boost the economy
an economy that had recovered
so well from the last crisis
i really acknowledge that and thanks to
the hard work
and to the sacrifice of the portuguese
people
i want the portuguese people to know
that
we are together in this and europe is
was and will always be firmly
by your side
you